[موسيقى]
9 ش
أهلا ومرحبا أهلا ومرحبا بالفعل
بيتراسانتا
اسمي باولو كارلي نحن
بالضبط على أعلى جبل في
قلب في جبل غني بالكامل
في هذا المحجر نقوم باستخراج الرخام
منذ 500 عام ونحن نستخرج معظم الكرات
التي يتم استخدامها
العديد من الأعمال المعمارية ه
فني في العالم ولكن هذا واحد
تاريخ قديم جدا
كان هذا الجبل في الغالب
اكتشفه مايكل أنجلو العصر الذهبي
ولد بيتراسانتا النحت
بالتأكيد بعد حضور
مايكل أنجلو تبدأ الأنشطة
الاستخراجية التي أيضا pietrasanta ويجدها
دور مهم في النحت
الكلاسيكية والدينية بشكل خاص
كمياتنا الاستخراجية تقريبية
20 الف طن سنويا
أفضل الكتل تأتي هذه الأيام
المختارة ننجح في الحصول على كتل
كتل كبيرة من
التوحيد دون كسر
بعد ذلك يتم نقلهم إلى
بقية مختبرنا
غابة البلوط أن تكون بعد ذلك في وقت لاحق
عملت في أشكال متنوعة
تشمل بطاقة تصميم معماري
من الجبل ومن المحجر الذي ولد هناك
النحت الأول
اسمي ماسيمو جاليني وأنا أفعل
النحات الحرفي بيتراسانتا هو
المعروف في العالم يشرح
نسخ كلاسيكية صنعة كلاسيكية
ولكن هذه العقود لديها الآن
معروف لأن العديد من الفنانين
أنتجت مهمة ساعات أو ساعات
أعمالهم في بيتراسانتا
عمال مثل بلدي وأكثر
نصنع لنا نسخ الأعمال الكلاسيكية
نسخ دينية كلاسيكية
أو في الواقع نحن نعمل للفنانين
لذلك نقوم بأعمال الفنانين
خلق هناك مختلف العمال
ثم مصمم التشطيب
ثم يصنع النحات تشريح القضيب و
المزخرفة سانت
أنا رينزو ماجي أنا نحات و
لذلك الرسام أن يتعلم ما وضعه
كان عمري سبعة في 74 باختصار ، واحد
ستين سنة وصباح الغد متى
أعود هنا ولا بد لي من تعلم المزيد
ما هذا
عمليا الرخام لحياتي
لأننا في هذا المجال نأكل نعم
أكل الرخام أنا الكتب
أنا أجعل نموذج القلم الوحيد بنفسي
أصنع نماذج من الطين ولكن
أنا أعمل بشكل عام أعيش في الرخام
أرسمها على الحجر ثم أذهب
مباشرة
أحصل على مساعدة من شخص ما
الابتكار مثل أقراص الماس ولكن في
عام ويفضل ويفضل
العمل باستخدام الأدوات في جهاز واحد
الوقت لا نقدر هي الأعمال التي
قد تكون قيمتها و 5000 إلى 50000 بالرغم من ذلك
أعتقد ذلك فأنا متواضع جدا
يعتقد أن تكون أكبر التماثيل من
العالم والذين يدفعون اقول
دائما من أجل القزحية عندما أموت
القبر يأخذ قطعة من الطاقة لأنه
في كل مكان ألتفت إليه توجد رخام حجري
تخطي أعني أنه بدون الرخام لا
لا أحد يعرف ذلك
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]